f are good want to buy all right go
darene do something ice that
boom my hot dog my hot dog I know they
be banged up yo I want to do this like
we could all be defensive offensive
players bro that be glitch
dang oh he dropped his stick what was
the call what's slashing what is that
what is slashing they start playing DMX
when they start fighting right but they
not slick for that that was a good save
caught that drawing like this
when you when you catch like
that
oh yo it was like in the air you know
what I'm saying yo that's a sports set a
top 10 play the puck was flipping in the
air he took his stick and was like
that's tough take that oh yeah boy yeah
boy yeah
[Applause]
boy that's what hey three more oh take
the shot see what I mean but they got a
wide open Lane they got to take that
right that's not that easy